the gyro can experience you know he's
standing like a striker he stands like a
striker like so does uh Jorge Matsui
doll yeah
he stands straight up Manny striking is
really like really good
does it get his fight with me it was
[ __ ] awesome nasty he's so good man
so good so clap so good so funny he's
hilarious
Thank You Solaris I really like both
those guys you know what else he is he's
[ __ ] mean that's a mean dude there's
something like when when they asked him
about the Ben Askren shot was it
necessary to punch him again on the
ground goes it was super necessary later
that became like a big hashtag super
necessary tool area hey man he's in the
[ __ ] hurt game you can't play your
[ __ ] for sure nonsense in the hurt
game and if everybody's picking a
gimmick or whatever then trying to push
them was trying to be Conner why not be
yourself who's [ __ ] late
ya mean you're mean yeah and super
talented so so Nick so much experience
people oh no that guy knocked out Eve
Edwards with a head kick and Bodog
mmm-hmm Eve Edwards Eve Edwards is a
slick striker especially back then that
was Eve add words when Eve Edwards was
arguably the best hundred fifty five
pounder in the world that was after he
knocked out Josh Thompson that highlight
reel where he throws that that round
kick spinning backfist he throws around
kicking catches him right in the net
still like the UFC's yep clip and it's
Josh buck and Thompson toughest guys
ever live another monster another
monster I mean that was the last guy to
knockout Nate before yeah before Bosma
Dahl had stopped him he was the first
guy to ever stop Nate right you know and
josh is as good as it gets you know when
you see that fight mean that was two
guys who easily could have done the same
to each other and just time didn't play
that way weight landed the perfect shot
he was a neck kick it was just [ __ ]
spectacular at that time Eve was thought
to be absolutely one of the very best
fighters in the world probably the best
hundred fifty five pounder a lot of the
UFC changed the division they gave up
the 155 division back then I remember
there was very disheartening yeah it was
like there's so much talent this
division but they were hemorrhaging
money man this is all pre Ultimate
Fighter they didn't know what they were
doing in terms of like the future they
were
million dollars in debt they're like
what are we doing gonna sell this we
gonna keep it they just had their balls
though Lorenzo Fertitta Frank Fertitta
and Dana when all three of them have
balls they were just like let's just
glitch this ride let's let it ride they
were calling Dana up go and look for a
buyer let's find a buyer we got to get
out of this like we're not gonna lose
our family's fortune
we're 44 million dollars in the hole and
this Cagefighting [ __ ] obviously this is
too brutal for America they're not
really into it then they figured it out
that ultimate fighters show they
financed the whole show paid for all of
it pay for the whole thing
paid to be on the network and then BOOM
that one final fight with Forrest
Griffin and Stephan Bonnar and these two
crazy [ __ ] are beating the [ __ ] out of
each other and it is a wild melee of a
fight and the viewership just keeps
going up during the fight
millions and millions of people watched
during the fight like tuned in extra
people tuned in because people are
calling the friends like bro you gotta
watch it
this is nuts and this affect people do
you even know what it was like what is
this what do they got little gloves on
what is happening here before the
Ultimate Fighter there was fans of UFC
or cage fighting a river but they didn't
really get to know who Chuck Liddell was
that much you didn't get to know those
people know what the Ultimate Fighter
was yeah they got to know these people
there was like a thing that grew and
then you saw this insane fight it was
yeah couldn't have played out better
yeah I mean good to play it out better
goddamn they nailed it and then BOOM and
that was a Craig polygyny show he was
the guy who did survivor like he knew
how to do those reality shows dude he's
a G he's one of the like the greats in
terms of that genre that guy knows how
to make those [ __ ] shows that's why
it was so good you know it didn't feel
like a clunky reality show it was a fun
reality show to watch so that although
they're bringing it back by the way
Paulo Costa in Israel out of Sanya
oh really yeah really holy [ __ ] tell me
not gonna watch the a because you're
gonna watch that that fight is a wild
fight man yeah you know because you see
is he a John Jones though honestly I do
too I do too but is in Costa has to
happen man
[Applause]